okay nate like you said love is in the
air and if you're lucky you'll catch a
surprise wedding proposal somewhere
along the strip every once in a while
but this one was extra special and went
extra viral so allow me to introduce you
to a couple that
gambled on love and won but with a
little help
hello everybody okay i'm so excited to
talk to you and share your story
you guys went go viral you guys went so
viral and chris
you are the photographer who helped this
couple get engaged
in vegas absolutely i was i was i had
the pleasure and the blessing of
capturing that moment
well let's just start off by talking
about your love story and how you got
here
we uh we met at clapton university in
2015
and um we actually were auditioning for
a dance team
at the same time and uh
she thought i was being mean to her and
uh
i actually was because i was kind of
flirting with her one of the head
choreographer she placed us together and
from there we just headed off because we
our chemistry when we started dancing
it was natural it was literally like we
already knew each other that's how i
felt with him i'm just like wow i'm like
really
comfortable around him but my next
question has to be just
what's your secret tell tell everybody
who's out there
looking to be in your shoes one day you
know
what it takes to get to where you are
and to get that proposal and
have that healthy happy marriage
definitely um i would say the biggest
thing is compromising
um communication is key well for me
it's uh listening probably you gotta
listen
um and just having fun like once you
just open up and have fun with each
other everything else is easy
we love our city why las vegas nate
so vegas was actually going to be our
first trip together on a plane
and we this is that was our first time
visiting vegas so
it was like that's the cherry on top
what was going through your mind
in some moments i really thought he was
in a photo shoot like
i'm like you know i got to get my angle
right he's like
i can't hear him say you know look at
your man look at your man but in my
eye i'm like in my head i'm just like
okay well whatever this next pose is
about to be it's about
bomb so okay let me get let me get the
angle right you know
and then when he said look down at his
head it still didn't click it just never
clicked
it took me forever to even say yeah like
i even realized like oh snap i have to
say
let's just talk about what goes into the
perfect proposal
for anybody out there who um is thinking
about you know making the move
you know what i would say most
importantly is that
you always just try to be as natural as
you can that day
and do something that's always going to
be memorable to her don't think about
yourself it's about her not about you
ooh we like that you like that kim yeah
oh my god i'll forever remember chris
for this like he nailed it okay
that's awesome well so since we're
talking about chris since we're pumping
you up let's talk about how people can
get in contact with you
if they want to do this for their loved
ones so on instagram
you can actually find me under chris dot
ch photographer on instagram
and then facebook i'm under ch
photography
they were so much fun that's really cute
i know i like her
getting into her pose she said you're so
focused on the angle
she didn't even realize her man was down
there but so cute we wish them the
very best so congratulations to kimya
and nate and you can follow their
journey actually on youtube now
at the gambles because once you go viral
it's like you gotta keep the energy
going
you know